تحول مفتاح الضاحية الهادئ إلى
جحيم
يمكن سماع أصوات صراخ
بعد دقائق من تحطم طائرة هليكوبتر
خارج مبنى سكني على بعد
خطوات من روضة أطفال
على متن قيادة
وزارة الداخلية الأوكرانية بما في ذلك الوزير
نفسه دينيس
موناسترسكي ونائبه يفين
يانين  كانت المروحية متجهة إلى مدينة
هاركيف عندما فقدت السيطرة
على روضة الأطفال حيث نزلت
قتل طفل واحد.
بمجرد أن سمعت الانفجار ،
رأينا فقط الأطفال المصابين الذين كانوا
يحترقون ، آسف قالت إنهم كانوا يبكون
ويهربون من المدرسة
[موسيقى]
فتحت خدمات الأمن الأوكرانية
تحقيقًا في الحادث في الوقت الحالي
وليس هناك ما يشير إلى أن لعبة Foul Play
كان هناك ضباب كثيف في
الصباح لكن الرئيس
فيلوديمير زيلينسكي قال كل ديما  كانت
نتيجة الحرب حتى عندما كانت بعيدة عن
الخطوط الأمامية ،
أصيبت زوجة نائب الوزير
يانين بالبكاء من الصدمة عندما التقطت في مكان الحادث
مأساة أخرى في أمة
شهدت الكثير من الرعب
حيث تلاشى ضوء النهار
أعلنت خدمات الطوارئ أن  انتهاء عمليات البحث
والانقاذ
ونقل الجثث بعيدا